guys we
did it we did it uh welcome back
welcome back to the stream on a saturday
i'm cold i got my snow coat on i'm
feeling really good though man i'm
feeling super good because
just put out this epic montage
from all of you guys all of you guys
like
rendered the coolest stuff and it was a
blast putting it together for for you
guys and casey dude with that soundtrack
oh makes it so nice so nice i couldn't
be happier with
the results of all this man is this is a
glorious stream so in celebration
um i'm just going to crack a beer here i
got some old halloween stuff left over
so
here we go yeah
cheers everybody
everyone's hard work this is super fun
super super fun
seriously i'm blown away with like how
this turned out it came together
man they really did uh if you hadn't
seen it
go check it out definitely check it out
uh it's only like five minutes long
um watch it over and over and over and
send it to all your friends because i'm
just super proud of it and i'm sure you
guys are too
oh man good stuff very very good stuff
i'm glad you guys learned some stuff too
um famous adoga you are not late it just
began
it just began
oh man i could watch this over and over
again
just the music and everything i spent so
long timing up these renders
to make it like have the right renders
fit
at the certain moment in the song that i
thought would match up
so it really turned out it turned out so
well
thanks to all you guys go check it out
if you haven't already
uh and if you enjoyed it share it it
really helps me
send it to uh to all your friends to all
the 3d people all around
or into this kind of stuff
all right um
tinum yeah the audio video sync was nice
thank you casey
worked hard to get the pacing right with
the with the footsteps
though his last version i was like ah
it's not quite right and he like
you know stayed up late and adjusted the
tempo and got it right
um and elise
welcome welcome heck yeah
yeah 2 20 when the lighting is on time
let's see what happens at 220
are you talking about the lightning oh
the lightning yeah absolutely dude i got
the sound design in there
got the uh some train sound design right
here on this one
all right so guys uh
what are we talking about today so
besides um how excited i am for finally
finishing this
render montage what are we talking about
so i'll say this probably one more time
for the people rolling in
we are doing um
character rigging we're gonna rig some
characters
i learned a lot um i'm having to do some
vfx
for a friend here for a mario parkour
video um so he wanted to add in
some of these uh mario characters and i
need to rig them up
and animate them and i don't know much
about rigging and animating
so i uh i watched some of my
my favorite uh dudes tutorials his name
is idesign ej
and he is the master when it comes to
you know like cartoony characters in
cinema 4d
so i i watched a few ej tutorials and i
want to share you guys
share with you guys the stuff i learned
um you know we got them
got this goomba all rigged up so we can
move them here but we can also
you know move them around here and have
them
animate and stuff you know you can go
too far with it obviously but like
you can do some like squash and stretch
kind of stuff
um you can even like scale them up be
like
you know get some goofy stuff going on
and
uh yeah we'll rig an animate up a koopa
as well
so i'll walk you guys through my whole
process with this i hope you i hope
we're all going to learn something today
um yeah i suck at animation honestly i'm
a noob
when it comes to animation not good
not good at all so it's an area that i
need to get better at so
that's what i'm trying to do today the
second thing that i want to talk to you
guys about it's in the title of this
video because it's character rigging
plus
nvidia gpu giveaway um and i couldn't
add all the other things that i was
giving away because
there's too many things so basically
here's the idea guys
over the last month i ran a render
contest
you guys saw the results right here um
in this epic montage i put together i
literally just dropped this video
like 20 minutes ago um
this video is a culmination of all the
renders all the submissions for this
render contest that uh my myself and p
and y
and nvidia they helped out by you know
giving me some
hardware to give to you guys so
hopefully they've been in touch with all
the winners
um but the idea here is that
even if you guys didn't have the ability
to render out something like you're
seeing here
um they got your back we all got your
back
so here's the idea
there's a link in the description of
this video
and it will take you here and the
contest is called expanding dimensions
it is
part two of parallel dimensions contest
with p and y
and nvidia so instead of having to
render
a whole thing like we did on the first
leg of this
all you got to do is scroll down here
yeah it's like what is it who am i you
guys probably know who i am if you're
here
here's the stuff you can win we're
giving away an nvidia quadro rtx 4000
an nvidia shield tv pro um
we are giving away a one terabyte
ssd and uh two usb
3.1 flash drives so it's a lot a lot of
good stuff that'll help you guys
up your um you know your setup at home
and basically all you need to do you got
15 days because
you have until i believe november 30th
to do
a few things you can enter it looks like
uh 20 times and all you have to do
is type in your info here and
it's going once you do this it's going
to present you guys with like a list of
like 20 things
that you can do it's stuff like follow
me on
uh on instagram subscribe to me on
youtube
follow pny follow nvidia watch some
videos
one of them is this video right here um
so it's just a number of things that you
guys can do that are pretty simple and
straightforward
and you'll straight up get up to 20
raffle tickets
um in the pot you got 15 days to do so
and you guys could win this stuff here
it's randomly drawn
and i'll be announcing the winners
on the fifth i believe
um pretty sure that that's the case
yeah um so
definitely uh check that out if you guys
want to win some cool stuff
how are y'all doing on this saturday
how is everybody doing oh yeah i forgot
to mention
it is not international this one is not
international it's going to be u.s
prizes
only it's a legal thing i know it kind
of sucks
i apologize but that's just the way it
is
when you're giving away this kind of
stuff
and shipping out these cards to out of
country it gets
difficult for a number of reasons i'm
still trying to wrap my head around it
but
it's a legal thing um
but yeah how are y'all doing i changed
my latency so you can actually like
communicate a little bit faster here
christian hey no worries man thanks for
stopping by at least say hey
finish that honest paper good luck with
it
yeah i apologize to any of you
international guys
i know there's a lot of them um you know
we'll figure something out for you guys
in the future here
um for the this
parallel dimensions contest there were
three international winners because
i you know you guys put in hard work and
i wanted to give you guys something so i
sent
out three of my professional photography
prints
your way they will be there in four to
six weeks
it's gonna take a minute um but they're
coming all right
so i wanna do more for you international
folks i know you guys make up the
majority of uh
of the stream here so
so hey let me test the latency how are
you guys doing i'm gonna
i'm gonna say uh i don't know
give me a thumbs up everyone give me a
thumbs up let's see how fast this is
and yeah my my camera is in vlog right
now
all right so that's like 10 seconds
sweet um tim what do you have to create
though you don't have to create anything
you're talking about for the contest
you don't have to create anything it's
just like a you know follow me
follow pny subscribe watch some videos
and you'll get a bunch of raffle tickets
to you know be entered in
the prize pool here to win these prizes
so it's not um
you don't have to create anything making
it easy the idea is that you created
something already for
the first leg of the competition and for
the people who weren't able to
make it a little bit simpler for you
guys so we're doing a whole whole other
round of prizes here
all right so
shall we uh shall we jump in
and see how how to rig this guy up yeah
carl did you put montage together with
music i did put the montage together
with music
uh there's a link at the way at the top
of the chat here i'm gonna copy it
and paste it for you all
because you guys definitely need to
check this out share with your friends
share with the family
i'm just really happy with how it turned
out
what's up everybody thanks for hopping
in thanks for joining
it's a saturday we're learning how to
rig and animate characters
i'm literally learning how to do this um
so let's let's figure this out let's
figure out how to rig and animate and
get this guy to
do a dance um it's a really cool method
that i learned from eye design
uh ej all right so shout outs to ej if
you guys don't know about ej
go check out idesign that's i like your
eyeball i design
so let me open up my my goomba my goombi
i'll get rid of this and all i have here
is a null object with
all of the parts of this goomby all up
in here right
so it's just very simple everything's in
the hierarchy you got your eyes and the
teeth and the body and
all that good stuff all right and we
want to be able to animate this guy
um and have them jump around right now
if i start pulling parts they're they're
not connected
they're just flying off left and right
nothing's connected and they cannot be
animated easily
so we want to make it as easy as
possible
to animate this thing
so here's
what we're gonna do basically if you
come into the deformers
little box here you can pull up the ffd
ffd is basically a box with points
that allow you to manipulate
your object here so the first thing i'm
going to do
is scale this box down so our
character fits right inside of this box
and i'm gonna come into
like a side view and just make sure that
this
matches up
just like that and then you want to make
sure you get it from this angle too
so we got your character sitting in a
box now
for this to work because we have points
if we go to point mode we can move this
around
and it's not moving the object yet we're
gonna have to drop it into the group
so it did a weird thing it like
pushed them all out so let's go back and
let's just adjust
the size of this box real quick
so i'm getting errors now that i have
not gotten before
so it looks like i just need to expand
this a little bit more something like
this
so that the character fits inside if the
character is sitting outside you're
gonna get some weird stuff going on
so i'll adjust the box just like this
and i want to scale up my character
so that it sits at the top and bottom of
this box
that's about right so now when i grab
these points
you know i can grab a row of points here
and
we'll move the character around like
this yeah
stands what's up dude you are 13.
that is awesome all you guys are so
young that is great
uh you want to say that you're inspired
and you're learning a lot
and you want to be as good as me one day
that's awesome dude keep it up man keep
it up
i still have a lot to learn as well so
as long as we keep learning that's the
whole point of these streams is we're
just trying to learn as much as possible
um so i think that's awesome man keep
learning
keep having a good time yeah how old are
you guys 14
you all are young learning so much
that's amazing
i really think it's cool if i started
doing cg when i was 13
i'd be a lot further along at this point
so please keep it up
yeah 23 21 99
sweet you almost made 200 all right 28.
so no one's no one is older than me yet
heck yeah you know you this is great
47. all right carl if you're legit 47
that's awesome melee 37.
melee i'm i assume it's melee not mile
right
sweet all right we got a couple we got a
couple people who are older than me
i like that it's nice but most of you
guys are young and learning
i love it everyone's here to learn it's
great
all right so back to it so we want to
move this thing around
and get them do a little dance right but
we don't
want to um we don't want to move this
around and animate these points it's
going to make it really
really ugly for us and again this is all
coming from ej
got it got gotta shout out the man ej
over at idesign
now my god there's some construction
being done
in the garage right over here
let me know how bad that is let me know
how bad that sounds hopefully it's
bearable
um so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna take these points
and we're actually gonna give it um a
joint system we're gonna add joints to
this guy
um and then we're going to control those
joints with null objects
right so
here's what we're going to do let's go
ahead and add some subdivisions to
our box
awesome awesome yep that should be good
there we want to just give it more
subdivisions that way it's able to bend
properly
um if you don't have enough subdivisions
you will
it won't bend properly it'll just look
really bad so make sure you give it
enough this is fine here you don't need
to go crazy with it
the idea is to keep it simple keep it
simple
wow throwing knife killer uh crazy name
but you've been watching since carbo
warfare and the freddy w days and 09.
that is
nuts man that is really nuts i'm glad
that you're hanging in there
and still watching because i'll still be
creating
as long as i live i will still be
creating
awesome awesome okay so let's give this
thing a joint system right
you know you can select these points and
move them around with the ffd
modifier but let's give some joints all
right so i'm going to go to character
and i'm going to grab the joint tool
specifically the joint tool let's go
into front mode here i'm going to hold
ctrl down
and basically give this guy
some joints and
that should be good you know it's just
four joints
through this guy um going up to the top
all right
so let's pull this root out
so this is our our system here our
skeleton system
let's go to the side view oh here's
here's something
so it's kind of squashed i don't like
that so
i'm going to scale
my model up again let's actually grab
these guys
and scale this properly
that looks wonky when
there we go that feels better
sweet okay cool so i just made that
quick adjustment and you want to make
sure that the bones
and the joints are lined up in the
middle of this guy that's pretty good
i think you can probably hit it like
right there or something
so now what we need to do is we need to
connect these joints
to the actual character or i'm sorry
we're not connecting the joints to the
character we're connecting the joints to
the um to the ffd to this modifier right
here
so here's what we'll do we're going to
select all those joints and we're going
to control click the ffd
and we'll go to character and i believe
it's bind and that created this
um this tag here this weight tag and
some
skin on our ffd
now when we go ahead and move
should be able to move this around yep
and get this thing to actually have some
motion here
just like that so what you could do
is you could say if you go in and i
think shift double click
this weight tag you will get
a breakdown of your joints
and what those joints what points those
joints
are affecting
so if we
click joint four or joint three you can
see
that these uh there's a selection here
um let me grab actually the character
and i believe it's the weight tool
and this will allow us to paint on
uh different weights and different
colors to these points
so you should be able to see i don't
know why
it's not showing up
but you should be able to see the colors
of all these
on these points here
because this is going to allow us to
basically say
if i want to move these points
so i'm painting joint 4 now this joint 4
and and joint 4 should also be connected
to this stuff down here so when i move
joint four
in theory
oh so that's join four that's gonna be
affecting the bottom so that doesn't
work you see how we painted on
those points down there for this for
this joint up here
doesn't work joint 4 we obviously if we
grab
our weight tool again we want to just
paint up the top here
so it's just these points that are
affected when we move that top bit joint
3 moving down
we want to paint these guys so joint 3
will affect
these guys and joint 2 will affect
this row and the last joint joint 1 is
going to affect the bottom
so now when we go in we really have
control over
you know what points are moving around
with each one of these joints
so this is like the entire goomba and
then you have like
this top piece you know whatever that's
going to be
so next what we want to do is we
actually want to control this
not by animating the joints but by
animating
null objects and it's going to make it
really easy as for
really easy for us to do that all right
so definitely make sure you guys
save i'm going to save this as
1c and i'm saving iterations because if
i do something here and i can't go back
far enough
i have earlier c4d files earlier save
files
in order to pull up stuff that you know
i just don't want to lose anything
so that's why i'm saving iterations and
that's something i learned from chris
schmidt over at rocket lasso
so shout outs to you chris
if you guys are wondering why the heck
i'm drinking a beer on my stream
i don't do that i've never done that but
it's because
we completed the epic render montage
everyone was given a template scene and
you guys
rendered your own environment out and
i you know casey put together some music
that is so epic and it fits this
perfectly
um so that's why i'm drinking beers
because i released this video
probably 40 minutes ago and it just
feels good
this is the first non-tutorial video
that i have put out
in about seven years that's crazy
that is crazy
oh man darius what are my thoughts on
blender dude i think blender is great
uh peter at corridor uses blender and he
does a lot of really cool stuff in it i
don't think
the issue there's no issue with any
program
um you know it's just whatever you have
at your fingertips whatever you have at
your disposal
um and it's not like blender i mean
all programs have a lot of cool stuff
and all programs have some things that
the programs don't have
you know that's just kind of the way it
is but i think no matter what program
you choose you're going to be awesome at
it if you put the time in to learn it
what's up juan from colombia thanks for
joining
yeah man i'm so happy with how this
turned out i am so so happy
um all right back at it back at it so
we're trying to control these joints
for this goomba character with some null
objects so here's how i'm going to do
this
again all this info is coming from
ej over at idesign his youtube channel
idesign
go check it out he is the master of
like cartoony characters incident before
d so
this is just something that i needed to
learn for a project
so i followed some ej tutorials and i'm
hoping that i just want to share that
with you guys and
if anything make you guys aware of ej
because the dude's freaking awesome
and it's i design like your eyeball
e-y-e
okay let's let's take these joints and
bring them up to some nulls
so i want to be able to control the
bottom and have this guy
if i need to like let me hide the ffd if
i want to have him go like
right i want to be able to control that
with a null so i'm going to select that
joint and i'm going to i believe
it is character
um convert convert to nulls
so you get this joint null that pops out
so i'll
bring that out there now it's just in
place of it it's not
doing anything we need to pair them
together
so i'm going to select joint one and
control click that joint null we just
made
go to character go to constraints
and add a psr constraint now when we
move this joint
it's going to move i'm sorry when we
move the null it's going to move the
joint
okay so what we could do
is bring them up here and if we want
this to be like the base
kind of uh ground zero for our character
we can go to the joint
and we'll go to coordinates and we will
freeze transformation right here freeze
all
so now if we move him flying over here
but it's like oh we want him
oh no i want him back at zero you know
you just reset psr and he's going to sit
right back there
so now that we have his like basically
his ground so i'm gonna call this like
uh
uh root
control if i can spell correctly
all right so our root control is doing a
thing let's go ahead and make that
null object a bit more visible i'm also
going to hide
the joints from our scene so we just
want it as clean as possible
so the root control if we go to object
the shape let's change it to a circle
and set it to z scale it up
and now we can just come in here and
just select that and
move them around so that's like our
controller
um next let's do let's do this other
joint here
so this is like you can see how this
joint is affecting the feet
i don't like that i'm wondering if joint
3
is a better better for the body
so joint 2 i want to go back in
and exclude the feet
from joint 2. so you guys saw how we did
that before right i'm going to bring the
ffd
back in shift double click
the weight tag that's sitting on our ffd
and let's go to joints and we said joint
2 is the one controlling our
feet now
let's go ahead and grab the weight tool
and i'm just going to control click over
these points down here
and it's still it's still getting the
feet and i think it's just because of
the way we subdivided the ffd
so that might just have to we might have
to live with that
we might have to live with that uh joint
three on the other hand can
control the head as well
right and it's still getting a little
bit of the feet
so let me just double check and make
sure
that our weight is correct so for joint
3
i'm going to control click and make sure
none of that stuff is selected
it's barely getting the feet i think
this totally works for us so let's go
back let's
hide the ffd clean things up joint three
is going to be our head control
so let's go ahead and do the same thing
right let's go to character
and we're going to convert that joint to
a null object let's pull it up
and let's call this head control
from here what i'm going to do is i want
to pair them again so joint three
i'm going to select it control click the
head go to character
constraint add psr constraint so now our
head
is controlled by this null object so
i'll take the head
i'm going to change the shape of that
null to a circle
set the orientation to z scale it up
and that is our head control so i can
move this around to animate
you know maybe he gets squashed
because you know these guys get crushed
down and squash and everything
so we could also do a top of the head
control as well so with this
last joint um let's go to
convert to null
we'll call this top control
select joint 4 control click the top
control so we have both of them selected
and we'll add a psr constraint
and let's go ahead and change that to a
circle orientation z
we'll scale it up just a little bit
and that head
is squashed down when it gets stomped on
so here's what we can do as well the
root control moves
like this so we we actually need to drop
the top control into the root as well
so the root controls everything but then
we need to put the head in as well
so it's just a you know parent child
situation so wherever this goes the
others do
and the top head wherever the head
control goes
the top head will come with and then the
top we can
move that down a little bit as well so
now we have full control over this
goomba
over this goomby um let's take all three
of those nulls
and set this as a as its base state so
i'm going to freeze all
under the freeze transformation
there goes that construction in the
garage i don't know if you guys can hear
that
you are welcome my friend you are very
welcome um
i'm happy to help and teach you guys
uh it's really fun for me i love sharing
my knowledge
it's really fun um
yeah it's a good time it's a really good
time i try to learn as much as i can
i got all my books over here you guys
can't see it but i got a bunch of books
self-help books and stuff and uh
i'm kind of addicted to learning so i
want to be able to share that with you
all
as well so thanks for coming to these
streams so consistently
let me ask you guys guys this how many
streams have you
seen of mine live how many times have
you popped in for a live
stream for more than like 30 minutes
favor favor yeah all of my videos get
posted
after i'm done doing the live stream it
all gets posted to the youtube you know
all right hey we got some newcomers
once xero awesome awesome that's
exciting
very exciting five three
blaster jacks probably all of them
completely until the end dude
cheers to you brother cheers
fps games yo welcome welcome i'm glad
you're here man
very cool tinum dude you've been
you've been here for a while that's
amazing
so if you guys don't know i have a 3d
community vfx server
uh discord server the link is in the
description it's open to everyone it's
free
um come on down come join in on the
weekly challenges we do them every week
i'll be reviewing
the weekly challenges here on the stream
pretty soon here
um but uh
yeah let's let's get back to the goomby
here mr goomby
so this is our goomba control
this is the goomba itself so i like to
just
that's our goomba these are our bones
controlling our ffd and this is our
goomba control
uh games game stud plays thank you
for the super chat i appreciate it he
says um i look up to you
and everyone from the quarter crew and
someday aspire to reach level work with
y'all
dude keep up the hard work man keep it
up
i promise it'll pay off consistency
always pays off so please keep it up
all right thank you for the super chat i
appreciate it
you guys are awesome vfx wizard our
second place winner in the united states
vfx wizard man what a what an incredible
render i'm gonna show you guys
mr vfx wizard let's see if i can snipe
it
it's coming up
he got his render in literally the last
second possible
there he is this is it right here
absolutely incredible
absolutely incredible i wish man the
compression is really like
knocking the quality down
that's the only bummer i wish it was a
bit crisper
but it's okay it's all good
i think the uh the feeling
of the entire render montage was
communicated properly
all right so
here we go we got our goomba he's moving
around let's just give him a quick
animation
let's give this a quick little goomby
animation um let's turn on
auto keyframes so every time we move it
it changes
i'm gonna go forward we'll want to
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
and we'll move them i don't know
we'll move them there and then let's go
another ten whoa another 10
and we'll move them there 30
40. i suck with animation guys
i'm really bad um
but we did have an animator come in for
animators react
over at corridor um he worked
at disney and he currently works at
dreamworks
he worked on frozen two he worked on big
hero 6
and i learned so much from that
interaction it was incredible
so right now it's gonna look like the
characters moving forward
like this i want them to like hop like
blink blink blink and move forward
the best way to do this jeez man um
i don't know let me see if i can get
this
down here
so he needs to hop up in the air
all right so every five frames he goes
up
and he's hopping and i think you guys
get the idea
and this is gonna look so bad when i hit
play
oh that's horrible yeah that's horrible
so i think the first thing i need to
do is change the keyframes on the ground
to linear keyframes and the ones in the
air can be easy ease so i'm just going
to click this button here
make them linear
okay still garbage
so let's go to the position
the why is it the z
okay it's the z so these guys
here they need to be rounded out they
need to look like
arcs and that's one thing i learned from
this animator
was that everything everything that's
natural is in arcs so you're getting
this like whoo
you know that kind of feeling so
i'm gonna want to pull these key frames
out to achieve that
arc now i mean right there it does not
look right
but it's getting better um
[Music]
so what i need to do
[Music]
i don't know why all right so maybe i
need to change
that and get this okay yeah there we go
there we go
i just need to get this arc looking
correctly so everything needs to be easy
ease i believe
now these points down here
can come to a point like a little pinch
point
and then these guys up top
can kind of crunch in a little bit
and that is your arc that's an arc right
there
so that looks a lot better it's
definitely
you know like a little bouncing ball
situation we got going on
that's not bad that's not bad i think
what we need to do
now is actually mess with uh with his
head and his body and have him squash
and stretch when he's jumping up and
down
so let's go to our goomba control
and it's the head
and the squat we're going to squash them
and we're going to stretch them okay
so let us
go
let's figure this out
so it's the head control that we need to
mess with
so i think he's starts
squashed and leaned
forward because you're you're
compressing yourself and you're
you're leaning forward and you jump
and land
oh man you know be crazy i'm gonna just
try this i'm gonna
i'm gonna see what happens if i if i
give the head control
a rigid body uh
or maybe it's a spring i think there's
like a spring
modifier or spring tag or something i
don't know much about that i'm gonna
just go with my gut
and i'm gonna give it a rigid body and
i'm going to hit play
first i'm going to save
basically i'm giving it dynamics
and nothing is happening
okay
oh
okay let's um
let's go to force and we'll crank up the
follow position and
follow rotation and see
what that does
and it's kind of like popping in and out
like let's set it to five
and five
he's doing a goofy thing for sure um
dampening what happens if i set that to
zero
that's pretty funny seven and seven
whoa that's dampening all the way up
and then maybe the follow position let's
give it
more bounce let's give it twenty percent
bounce and
zero friction
and this is just me goofing off like
lift 20 percent lift so it may be 100
lift
and the gravity we can actually set
by hitting control d we can go to
dynamics and
expert no it's uh
where's gravity here oh here it is here
it is 393 inches i got myself in inches
so let's just set it to like 100 inches
so
we're having gravity kind of pull things
up a little bit maybe we'll set it to
200 just to counteract some of that
and then it's popping really hard so
maybe the follow position is like
six percent i don't know six and six
it's interesting you know it's
interesting
it's not the best look um here's also
another thing
we can do we can set up a camera and
give it a target
um where are you animation we'll give it
a target and the target will be
the
the top control we'll go in there
and we'll zoom in
like 150
and maybe
that's really intense that's really
intense
it's funny this is a way for us to track
our character
we could change it to the goomba control
itself
but then it doesn't really look like
it's doing much
so maybe the head control
a little disorienting just a fun little
trick that you can do to
track your character with so
let me take off the dynamics i'm gonna
delete that and let's try it
manually okay so
i'm just gonna go for it like so leaning
forward
jumping you come up right land and you
kind of roll into
you kind of like roll into your next hop
so maybe he's leaned
forward
jumps up
so it's a stretch and a lean
back
and then when you come down
it's another squash
and roll forward
like that so the momentum is coming
forward jump
up comes back
and forward boom
same deal and keep it up this actually
works yeah i've just moved forward every
little moment here make a quick
adjustment so that
it locks in the keyframe and then we'll
go to the landing
portion and really squash them down
and just give it a little bit of
variation
let's see what that looks like
god dang it nothing happened because my
auto keyframe button wasn't on
see these are the things that happen
y'all this stuff just
happens alright so
let's go through again and make those
keyframes
till we get to the end and then we'll go
to the top
and we want to rotate them back pull it
up because he's in the air
and that's going to be
the vibe on that
let's see what it looks like
weird okay so it's not
it's not recording the squash
bit
so i think i'll need to offset those
up and down
up and down
it's working now up and down
and that's really extreme that's like
really extreme but
that was another thing that the animator
talked about was like
you really want to kind of over
dramatize these movements
and you'll get to the point where you
can like really feel it out it just
takes a bunch of different
iterations so this doesn't look right to
me it feels
too too static
and the there's no weight there's no
weight so
what i need to do is
my head control
and
what do we need to do
so position and rotation
so we need to go for those arcs again
we're not seeing arcs here
so
i'm wondering if i can offset the head
control
the keyframes of this a little bit and
i'm wondering
if that would actually help
like he's trying to scoot himself along
so i think the best way to do this as an
amateur animator
would be to just take a lot of time
to get this right and to just work in
these details
for hours and use reference
of different animators to see how they
animate
[Music]
it's just a long tedious process
which originally the uh
the title of this stream was
try to rig and animate or
it was how the heck do i do i rig and
animate
so this is the this is me asking myself
this question
how you guys doing we got some thumbs
ups you guys doing all right today
thanks for joining me on the stream
it's a good time i'm just so glad that
that video is out and awesome
the render montage definitely check it
out if you haven't seen it
so nickname um
[Music]
the idea with this setup is that you
have bend squash and stretch modifiers
built in to
these nulls and um you kind of have
even like a twist as well you know you
kind of have everything
built into all this stuff so
at least that's when uh when i learned
this technique from idesign
that was his whole thing is like it has
everything built into this method
which i think is awesome so as a test
i'm gonna try and rig up something a bit
more complicated
so i'm gonna open up a koopa
and see how this is gonna work
so we got mr koopa
and i don't know much about connecting
four limbs together and and all that but
we're gonna try it's one model
um i'm gonna give it that uh
the ffd cage scale it down
apologies on the construction in the
garage guys
it's uh it's a thing but it's all good
hopefully it's not too loud
so once again we're going to scale the
cage around
our koopa
and make sure it fits properly
all right so i'm wondering when i scale
it like that
i think it's actually messing with
the model itself so let me try this
other method here
and instead of scaling it i'm just going
to mess with the grid size
and i also want to make sure my scaling
is right so i always spawn a figure
and the figure will help me determine
um the scale of my of my object because
this is a normal
you know this is like five nine this
person's five nine so
this koopa is a little too small
i'd say something like that and then i
want the gizmo to be at the center
bottom of this thing
so i'm gonna use the access center tool
and
we're going to execute so this
is right in the center and i'll drag the
y down to zero so it's sitting right
there and then we can zero out the koopa
so he's sitting right in the middle i'm
also going to turn them around
180 degrees
and check my gizmo
tool and zero that out so now
it's all set up so let's get this
ffd around our koopa
and then instead of scaling it i'm going
to do it with the actual grid
because i think this is actually messing
with
my mesh it's really dense
there's a really really dense model and
this is why this trick
works so well in my opinion
is we're able to control
this super dense mesh with a very simple
setup
uh matthew yo thank you for the super
chat he says thanks for making these
tutorials without it probably wouldn't
be where i am today dude that's awesome
man it's only been a year
too no and it's been less than a year i
started doing these
um man in march
of this year so thank you for sticking
around and
and learning with me man i think it's
awesome
all right save your work
let's make a null i'm gonna put the
koopa in a null and i'll drop the ffd
in there and yep it works so now
when we move these points around it will
move
our koopa
but we want to control them with the
joint system and the null system that we
had set up before
so
let's go ahead and add some
some lines here and some detail on our
mesh i think that
is probably good for the front maybe
i'll do one more
so we'll go 5 and
i'll do 6 for
the y and the z will do
[Music]
maybe 5 as well so this is our cage it's
a bit more advanced
than the first one but
that's because it needs to be
we can select these points here and have
them like
lean forward lean back
and we can maybe pick like
these points oh these points here
deselect those ones and like that's like
our our leg
or something you know
so maybe i'll give them one more
bit there so it really gets these front
legs
moving and separate from
those back legs
cool yeah i think that'll that'll work
nicely
so these little cubes that are
controlling this thing
fit to parent all right what does that
do nope
doesn't work okay
so from here we need to do our joints
now connecting
different joints we're going to see
about that um let me do a
test in a new scene so let's go
character
joint tool come in to our
side view holding control let's just say
that's a foot that's an oop that's a
foot that's a knee
those are the hips
and that's where it's meeting is at the
hips maybe
one two three and then
you have the spine
the shoulder elbow hand
but what if i wanted to select that one
could i branch off
so how can i connect
this to here like if i wanted to branch
off do you guys know does anyone know
the answer here
colin i'm glad you enjoyed the montage
um i hope to do more contests like that
in the future
it was really fun
all right so you always start with a
pelvis when you make a rig absolutely
right because that's in the center so
let's just say
that's our pelvis
and we come off to some like hips
and then the knee and the foot basically
yeah i want to combine these
and i don't know how is it
got to select the joint
huh
yeah i don't know i'm a little stumped
on this one
yeah but you make it a child i guess i
guess you would but
i don't know
okay you i got you you need to unselect
rooting on the joint tool
once this is done
thinking
who knows if it's crashed
all right i'll give the old reboot
it happens y'all it happens even on the
best of computers the best graphics card
you get the crash
it happens so say often say frequently
man i am tired i stayed up last night
finishing that render montage
but it's worth it absolutely worth it
i'm just excited to take a break i need
a break we just moved into a new place
moving is very very stressful because
all your stuff is everywhere and like
you don't know where stuff is
all right let's do this test again
character
joint tool
[Music]
let's hop in here we got the hips the
knee
the foot now if i deselect
to child what is it chain
oh symmetry okay
so that'll work i guess
ah so look at that you got some symmetry
on that side
interesting
wow why is it way over there
root and all right so the root no box
if we uncheck it
there we go it's exactly what i need all
right so that's
that's that's what i need to know so
back to koopa
um the mesh is really intense
i wonder if there's a way
if i hold alt i could throw a
[Music]
where would you be polygon reduction
where's the other way around drop the
polygon reduction into
the object maybe
there we go all right so bottom left you
can see it thinking
so it's going to do its thing and it'll
actually it'll allow us to work a little
faster
um this thing's ridiculous a ridiculous
polycount because it was made for
3d printing
all right hey uh why mar
you're asking me a legit question right
now you're saying do i remember a web
series called
pure ownage
now i wish i had
some memorabilia around but absolutely
it's one
i think it was the first web series
maybe
i even got to work with fps doug in
cardboard warfare 2. he was the main
dude
and i met uh jeff and jarrett
and it's how i got my name the punisher
is from that show
so of course i remember that show
uh i may have been on the forums i don't
remember
it was a long time ago but man i
followed the crap out of that show
i used to have a dave t-shirt um
man yeah i think i was there i met them
in in toronto
um i freaking love that show so much
dude yeah it's the best
it's absolutely the best show ever if
you guys don't know about pure onage
go check it out it's crazy it's where
the term boom headshot came from
um from fps doug god what a great show
boom headshot i could dance all day i
could dance my day trying to be trying
to hit me boom
yeah freaking joel man
so good i love him he's the best
wait you were in that show
what
what the heck in the tv series or the
the um the web series
that's hilarious dude that's amazing
all right you can see we can actually
see our koopa a little bit better now so
here's
here's what i'm gonna do the hips
let's figure this out though let's grab
the joint tool hold control
that's our root null we're going to come
down here
um that's the foot what happened to
oh okay okay this just needs to get
pulled out
wait they they based the character in
gta on him
on jeremy that's amazing i didn't know
that
all right way more the web series the
web series was the best the tv show was
was not that great but the web series
that's what that's what's up was it
season one or season two
you said you're a big contributor to the
community and they ended up selling
jeremy's hair on ebay
got three thousand and flew over the
netherlands to surprise a few fans me
included wow
dude that is awesome the ponerer man
that's how i got my name the punisher
that's
awesome what a freaking great show
all right so with the
joint tool selected let's uncheck root
null
and
click i'm holding ctrl and i'm clicking
and then i can actually move
these here
um
we want a spine so the spine goes
from here
i'll say like one
and one two three
like that and then we really can't do
much
more until we hit a side view because
the side view is where let's see
let's start naming some of this stuff
because it's a little bit more
complicated
this is um these are our hips
um that looks to me like
let's see hips
spine one
spine two
and spine three
yep the spine is horizontal it
definitely has to come from back here
and connect and everything
so we got to do a few things um this guy
is going to be
foot end
foot end and then we have
leg it's gonna be right
leg this is left
leg um
we have our spines
this is our spine end which will
probably change because that's going to
go into the neck in the head
um
so the hips
are kind of like
back here
these are the hips
probably right in there spine one
which these can kind of tilt
down like this
spine two spine
three like it wants to go right into the
neck
and from here we're gonna grab that
joint tool again and
keep clicking we have a mouth
and then from here we can go up
one and
two and then from here we'll go one
two so that's kind of it's like little
beak
and it's mouth um
so that's mouth
and this is i've legit never done this
before this is fun
mouth this is like
well that's neck that's head this is
probably
jaw um
that's going to be your neck
dude is it gonna crash again
i don't know why keeps doing this
blaster jacks okay random question but
any suggestion tutorials or channel for
beginner
unreal engine yes um check out
winbush win bush he is the dude to
go with um he just released a
really long training video on
mograph.com
it's like 250 bucks but it's
legit and then there's uh joe garth he
just released
a learn squared is that the website
um environment class and it's like
half off i bought it for a hundred bucks
so i'm gonna be going through that
alpha matte yeah no it's screwed up bone
structure no doubt
it's ridiculous it was a cartoon
character oh
god dang it why
all right reload
yeah agreed i think the the skeleton
would be similar to a dog
bone structure
all right look y'all y'all aren't
feeling the uh
the color profile on the camera i'll
switch it for you
i will do that
all right let's see though real quick if
i can get a backup running
uh rename
button
what
incorrect file structure what does that
even mean
[Music]
uh
after effects c4d models
coupon backup c4d file
[Music]
incorrect file structure
what
all of this is just trouble shooting
y'all troubleshoot all day
c4d
all right i tried hey the more you do it
the better you get
uh i just gotta save more often
save more often okay
second time's a charm absolutely
absolutely all right hey let me get that
rec709 for you
gotta squeeze back behind the desk
all right
how's that any better
maybe a little bit yeah that's a little
bit better
okay
let's maybe start from the side view
i think that'll probably be the best way
to go
get that polygon reduction going again
[Music]
see i'll help me make the stream better
awesome i'm not in a depressed ad
anymore says charles
why don't y'all tell me i look like i
was in a depressed ad man
all right
wonderful wonderful all right let's
let's do this
uh character joint tool
here we go
i want to keep this simple alright so
one
uh two
a knee a hip
or do i go backwards now i go hip
knee toe
all right so then from the root null we
come and we do
a spine which might be something like
a tail and then
some sort of arc
scoliosis and then
one two
three
we got a mouth we got a freaking nose
clamp um
[Music]
this
right where are you
here is this the one i'm looking for
i guess it'd be more something like this
right
something like that
all right the joint tool is going to
help me move this stuff awesome good to
know
that's all jacked up okay
something like that maybe and then we
break off we go
one two three
that might work that might work
so in front view let's hide the ffd
for a second
i need to grab
let's see i need to grab most of these
joints
so that's the hip okay from the hips
we come out
yeah we come out oh god okay
hey too much too much sauce all right
come up by three and then the neck
comes back to the center line
okay
and the
these guys this is looking gross
god what kind of creature is this
these guys uh
that's the tail i think this is neat
this needs an
extra piece
this is so jacked up this comes
out oh my god one two
three
and the spine
definitely comes back in same for this
piece
and technically this piece too i need a
piece that comes from here
and goes
[Music]
back to the center
huh i don't know how to add one
maybe that all needs to be done from the
top
all right so a4 says start pelvis the
spine
the neck and head then add the legs
after
fourth time's a charm that's the way to
do it
that's the freaking way to do it okay so
i start from the
i start from the the side view
here we go okay
the pelvis boom uh
root null i'd say the back legs
is a pelvis control click boom all right
some sort of janky spine system
coming up in here all right the neck
the jaw the head i'm gonna break off of
this the root null
and hit the tail i'm also going to hit
the jaw
and this for again mouth clamp unless
that is it like right there
like that
um from here okay yeah i got you
go to top view
and branch off so these are
can i do symmetry bone um
symmetry
world
now why isn't it not connecting um root
or
parent
i don't know why this isn't connecting
on that side
yeah kind of stumped on that one
real jesus
you are correct sir
you are absolutely correct
and don't be deceived i just suck
at this
thank you djb thank you
okay so i'm trying to figure out how to
get symmetry working
it's not the worst if i don't
world xy no
that's it but it's not connected
so i'm gonna turn it off for now
awesome so we got that
then from here
let's hide let's maybe hide these and
we'll get
these guys
all right that works
now let's get the front legs
so that's going to be this guy here
and then
all right i don't think that worked
so this joint here is where we want to
[Music]
come off of we'll get those
okay i think that works and then we also
want to break off of this one too
nope wrong one
and we'll get those last ones so i think
that's everything
if i hide the body
that's it that's a koopa skeleton
so let's bind it make sure we save
see you blaster jacks peace out
so i don't think this thing needs to be
too complicated and too over the top
i think this will totally work for like
what i'm going for
carl yo thank you for the super chat
brother says yo
uh hey clint been watching you freddie
and corridor for 11 years now that's a
long time
it's about as long a little longer than
i've been
uh out here back in california you know
the reason i'm pursuing a career in
movie making so thank you
keep it up you keep it up sir keep going
on that career
i'll be doing the same and we'll uh
we'll knock it out together man
so thank you thank you for the super
chat appreciate it
okay so let's bind this thing man i've
never done anything this crazy before
i'm gonna take all these joints i'm
gonna select every single joint
control click the ffd uh go to the
character and hit bind
and it totally did a thing
so now when i move
these joints around
hopefully
hmm
why didn't that work
all right so the points work
dude indy mogul yeah that was the best
anymore goes the bomb that's actually
another guy who had um
the honor to work with was eric beck he
helped me out on
speed enforced by aircraft a short film
i did over at rocket jump
um he built this like silicone baby with
an umbilical cord that
flies out of the ceiling or the roof of
the van
so that was awesome it was really really
cool to meet him because he was
definitely an idol for me
all right so why
so it's it's kind of working but it's
not
entirely working and i don't know why
the legs aren't
moving um did the bind not work
what is wrong
i don't know the answer
now the skin is definitely no this in
this case the skin is a child of the ffd
so i know that's supposed to be correct
do the bones have to be on the points
um
no the bones do not have to be on the
points
oh man is it a weight thing if so it's
going to be nuts
i wonder if i can just do this instead
of on the ffd if i can just do it on the
model itself let me try
let me give this a shot let me actually
first
i'll bake down let's go ninety thousand
polygon or ninety percent
something like that okay i'm gonna hit c
and make it editable
let's select every joint
shift click this uh the default model
i'm gonna delete the ffd
and i'm gonna see if i can't just do
this to the actual
model itself character
bind
why is it not working
okay
so it is working
i just need to paint these
weights that's really what needs to
happen here
so apologies for the construction
once again someone's definitely knocking
yep installing lights in the garage
it's a thing
so this model was downloaded
edge loops edge loops are but
but is there a quick way edge flow i
don't know what edge flow is
huh what is edge flow i know i need to
weight paint this thing
yeah it's difficult it's a difficult
process
and i don't think i have time to do that
on the stream here that's a lot
but let's just see let's see what it at
least looks like the weight
weight tool yeah
so it's just gonna be a lot of this you
know um
that's what is that the tail or the hips
so basically weight painting is
the idea that when you
move
a certain point um
it influences what is selected here
so i think it's actually covering a bit
too much ground
and then you gotta smooth it too
so let's see mode
smooth
and you got to smooth this out and do
this for every joint
you're right the shell should not move
with the leg
100 percent you are correct
why is that not
weird
man that's a whole thing
very very complicated is there a faster
way to do this
oh boy
certainly a process um
i don't think we have time to wait paint
this entire thing
i thought the ffd situation was going to
work i think i just need to
wait paint the ffd those points i think
that's really what i need to do
because this is too much and you saw the
way it actually deforms this thing it's
like really chunky
so that's why the ffd method works so
well is that it controls it in a really
fluid
way so um
oh there's an automatic way check the
gear next to bind
okay
so those are my weights on the model
let's go and check that gear
smoothing okay smooth iterations
yeah this is this is dense this is dense
here's what i'm gonna do
i gotta take a quick break i'm gonna
play the render montage for you guys
um in fact i'm gonna drop a link for
y'all
right here check it out if you haven't
checked it out already
i'm gonna start playing this thing
but i'll be back in three minutes
see you guys soon and when i get back um
i would love to go over the winners of
this week's weekly challenge the prompt
was recreate a movie frame
or a tv uh like a like a tv show frame
or something
um and we'll wrap up the the lesson here
on rigging i know i learned i learned a
lot just doing that right now
but i'll be back in like three minutes
so i'll see you guys soon check out the
running montage it's a good time
everyone put a lot of work into it all
right i'll see you guys in a second
be back shortly
what's up what's up everybody
i hope y'all enjoying the render montage
i'm excited to watch it again when we're
done streaming
all right so
for those of you guys who don't know
real quick i want to say
again that uh nvidia and pny
we're going to be giving out some
awesome pc
hardware there's a link in the
description
of this video all right um
it'll take you to this page here we're
calling it expanding dimensions that is
uh the next contest
parallel dimensions was the render
contest expanding dimensions
is basically um allowing anybody to win
you don't have to render anything you
don't have to do anything
other than basically sign up here
and you have 20 different things you can
do to enter
you can enter up to 20 times and it's
stuff like subscribe to my youtube
channel
if you're already subscribed just you
know check the box it'll verify that
you're subscribed
and you get a raffle ticket basically um
it'll be like follow me on instagram
follow pny watch a few videos
uh one of them being this render montage
so it's a bunch of small stuff that you
guys can do to
enter up to uh 20 times i think
is the max and you'll be entered into a
raffle to win some awesome prizes
the first place randomly pulling it out
the hat
nvidia quadro rtx 4000 we're giving away
an nvidia shield tv pro
a one terabyte ssd and some usb 3.1
flash drives
it's all random and this is us only so
um definitely sign up put your name in
the hat here
uh us only just because of the prizes
there's
legal reasons as to why pny and nvidia
cannot ship
internationally i know it's a bummer but
you know it's just the way it is that's
that's how these contests are
um so yeah there's a link in the
description definitely sign up if you
guys are in the us go for it
um have a blast and
yeah we're i was left off weight
painting this thing this is going to
take a minute
i'm at a standing desk my feet hurt um
and i need a break because you know i've
i've been up all night finishing that
render montage
so i'm going to call it here i look
forward to
digging into this a little bit more um
i'll definitely let you guys
know what i find in the discord server
if you guys want to join that it's a lot
of a lot of good time a lot of great
people
a lot of fun people sodamonte is the
moderator
one of the moderators on the discord
server as well as the chat right now
so thank you sotomonte for all of your
help i really appreciate you
oh good man um so
let's go ahead and talk about the
winners
of the weekly challenge every single
week i host the weekly challenge
i'll be hosting one and presenting you
guys with the prompt
as soon as i'm done choosing the winners
from last week so if you guys want to
join that
definitely do so it's a lot of fun it's
a whole lot of fun
um so the prompt was recreate a movie
still
or a tv show still
um and you know i
didn't have enough time to go over
and choose the winners um because i was
so busy trying to get this render
montage out
i did have time to look at them though
however so what i'm gonna do with you
guys
is go over them together and we're gonna
choose
the five winners live right here on
the stream all right so
let me see i want to definitely make
sure that
uh i'm able to show my discord
um let's go to the
weekly challenge and we'll hit the
submissions
yeah i think this is good all right
so
here we go we got a lot a lot of fun
submissions from you guys
we're just going to start right at the
bottom and work our way back up to the
top
and pick the five winners you guys will
be featured here on the right
the challenge winners um
you guys you know i'll choose five of
you and you guys will be right up at the
top here and you'll have the
the challenge winner discord roll on the
server which is a bunch of bunch of good
stuff
good times so the first one here's our
reference
and here's the render all right not bad
not bad i think a bit more detail work
could have been done here you could have
had some more texturing here on the car
some more detail work on the ground most
definitely i think um you got your
shapes right though
i really like your shapes and i think
you got the lighting correct you just
need to go in and keep adding more
detail
certainly keep adding more detail all
right next
we got this thor one here by ab abilash
this is the render this is the reference
which also looks like a render
a little confused there's two renders
i'm not sure which one is
the one
i don't know but i can see your
displacement map your lighting i think
you need a little bit of path tracing
some bounces and whatnot i can't tell
which one's the reference of the render
uh i guess i
i guess this is the render yeah it's got
to be a movie frame
gotta be a movie frame here's one
oh blaster jacks picked a really
ambitious one so this is
silicon valley um
i don't see the reference
i've never seen the show
but this looks really cool um
looks like a lot of work went into doing
this one a whole lot of work
this looks awesome very very cool
jacob no you cannot join the discord
server there are two discord servers one
is for
um the corridor disc discord server
one of them is for the office
that that's us in the office um
so for like daily office stuff but then
there's a corridor discord one
um for like fans and whatnot that's that
would be one that you could join
certainly so
yeah the silicon valley one that's
really nice really really good job
um it's hard to say without the
reference but
i think it's pretty solid all right
here's one here's the original shot
from spider-verse and
the uh the render
says my beginner level attempt v cole
i think this is good good work very good
work
all right uh okay the vfx wizard
here's a good one so it looks like this
is the reference from harry potter
and this is the render and that's pretty
freaking close to me
i'd say this one gets a star
so definitely noting this one here
here is another really good one by inti
here's your reference this
looks like it's from a uh
god what's that director what's his name
he did the uh
shoot what is it the hotel movie
there you i forget i forget his name
this is i'm brain fart here
it looks like one of his shots you guys
probably know i'm talking about here's
the render
very nice very nice i think you're
missing some
surface imperfections everything looks a
little too clean
you might have a couple here on the
ceiling it looks a little low poly up
here
um
you know i think it's the lighting maybe
perhaps i don't know what renderer you
you're using but it's not bad it's
actually really not bad at all
it does look like the shining a little
bit yeah this does look a little bit
like the shining
um wes anderson that's the one i was
thinking of okay is this shining
the old creepy lady in the bathtub
this one is incredible this is by ronan
so you got your reference obviously
and then you have your render this one
is
really good this one is a really really
good so
far if i had to pick a winner this would
be the winner
it's really well done so ronan
fantastic job all right here's the
reference
and here's the render it looks really
good
that's by tinum this is also
i'd consider this one a winner as well i
think the only difference between these
i'm seeing the ear i've seen a lot of
the ear
and i'm seeing some noise and grain in
the image
i'd probably add some noise and grain
i'd want to see his ear a little bit
more
but that looks really good
that's a fantastic render
i'd say those are the two winners right
now in my book
here's uh the reference and here is the
render
not bad not bad at all um
looking for a little bit more detail on
the ground i think
the lighting could have been tweaked a
little bit more
um it would have been nice to have some
snow coming down as well but you did a
good job modeling the building
texturing isn't bad but it's really the
ground that's getting me i feel like i
could see
a bit more detail on the ground based
off of the
the original and some fog too in the
background would be nice
but not bad work ai
satan here's your reference
also from blade runner and your result
that looks really good that looks
really good it almost looks like like
some half-life something
yeah this one's not bad at all
i like this one a lot i'd consider this
one a winner so far you know
your spot might get taken we don't know
because we're not done alright
um the exorcist here's the reference
and here's the render not bad work
really not by work just the tree that's
getting me man it's the tree
that low poly tree uh just doesn't feel
right to me
but you did a good job with your
composition and with your lighting
philly did a really nice job
alright bgi here's your reference don't
know what this from maybe gravity
and here's your render beautiful
absolutely beautiful i don't think
there's anything wrong with this
except that you could have fallen off to
black hello
thank you
it's kombucha my favorite
it's the fall edition apple turmeric
carrot and spices yay thank you
that's awesome
all right so i think the only thing
that this render could have improved
upon is the black levels
you could have fallen off the black but
that's it
oh joel music here's the reference
and the render very well done very well
done i like this one a lot
it's not bad at all um i think
you could have worked your color
correction that really would have helped
a lot you could have darkened it on this
side
and kind of had it gone from dark on the
right to bright on the left
and i'm missing that here it also feels
like the blue is lifted a little too
high
you just needed to crush the black
levels a little bit more on this one
that'd be my only nitpick um i would say
surface imperfections but
the original is pretty clean
yeah another blade runner
the original wait is that the original
oh yeah and this is the this is the
render okay
so with this one the biggest thing i'm
seeing is the repeating pattern in the
background
um in the ground texture
that's the biggest thing for me and also
the lack
of fog like the fog here is very
specific
and you just aren't hitting it quite
enough here it's a little too bright
this fog is a bit more subdued and gray
but i think your tree looks really nice
the the vehicle itself good job if you
modeled that
that looks really nice um i think you
just could have connected the tree to
the ground a little bit more it's really
just the ground that's bothering me and
this
the fog here
oh my goodness visual always with the
best renders
this is the reference
and the render is like somehow better
it's so good it's so good
um this is definitely a winner in my
book
i love your renders visual he won first
place
in the international leg of the parallel
dimensions contest
absolutely great work here's another one
by tristan
this is the render i believe
this is the reference
and this is the render yeah really good
work this is close
very very close i love it i think you
got
really close there um mr ant
cmdo is
your render
this is the reference
all right yeah this is a tough one i
really like your lighting i think your
lighting is spot on i just think you
need
more detail in the
in the castle your bricks are way too
large you need to scale those bricks
down
those are some huge bricks um
i think overall it's just your texturing
is a little too large
you need more detail in your model
um and i think if you spent another
week on this one you could really get it
to a really nice point
but i think you did a really good job
with the lighting
so congrats on that
all right paradox
cool cool all right so here's the
reference
and the render
i love it the head bump
oh so good yeah the head bump is great
um with this one i feel like i don't
know what you use for your renderer
um it does feel like a little video
gamey to me
um i think you could have
you know again i talk about the renderer
you know if you use path tracing i think
you would have gotten some really nice
light bounces down here and i think your
texture
is a little too rough it's blurring out
these highlights a little too much
compared to
the crisp highlights you see on the
actual stormtroopers so definitely watch
out for that
it looks like the original has a blue
tint and you
have a neutral tint there's no tent on
yours so watch out for that as well
we got the matrix um
let's see this is the reference without
the car
and this is the render with the car not
bad
not bad i'm missing the underside of
the underpass of this tunnel
it's very dark up here so i would you
know
what what are causing that what's
causing those you probably have a
giant light source right off the camera
here
blasting through and and hitting this
wall right here it looks actually might
look like the
the light source is hitting the ground
and it's
bouncing off the ground and causing
some light to bounce around the inside
of the tunnel
so i would double check your light
source i'd probably come up here
i'd blast it really hard on the ground
to bounce this light
around the inside or maybe it's just
color correction i don't know
but that's good i think this is nice i
love this shot it's one of my favorites
and that's it that's it everybody so if
i had to choose five winners
if i had to choose five winners
where would i go with i think visual is
one
this one's really good joel
space one's good that's three
um tinum isn't that's incredible
and ronan is absolutely incredible
man this is tough this is really tough i
think
ronan and
tinum are winners for sure
you guys congratulations on winning this
weekly challenge your renders are
incredible
this is amazing it's really hard to do
but you got it and same here like
this is this is crazy
this is really really good so
congratulations to both of you guys
uh to tinum and to ronin for winning
this week's weekly challenge
i'm gonna add you guys right now let's
see
let's give you guys the challenge winner
roll
bam added sweet so congrats i got three
more i gotta
i gotta pick three more ah
this one's good
um
this one's good this one's
good the tree though this one's good
like this one i like this one i just you
know there's there's certainly
the color correction element to it that
i think could could be fixed but i do
really like it i think it's really well
done and i think the model looks really
good
so that one i got that one in mind
uh visual i think i think
you're gonna be a winner this is really
good
your colors are incredible
and your render quality is always
amazing
but i'm still holding on to it
all right tinum or i'm sorry visual you
are a winner
you're already a winner from last uh
from the last one
but you've won this one as well all
right
so that's three congratulations visual
um i got two more joel i'm feeling like
you're gonna be winner you're gonna be a
winner this week man congratulations
you got the challenge winner roll um
very nice render very very nice i would
love to just see that
that fix that color correction to match
it
to this one here i think it would it
would
really really make it shine make it a
little bit better
match your black levels and it'll be
good so the last two
probably between our space
render
this one's really good too man this is
tough
and the matrix the matrix is really good
oh man guys
guys guys this is difficult
silicon valley one is incredible too i
just wish there was a reference
i'd love to see a reference to this but
if we're talking about
matching the render to
the example vfx wizard you're doing a
really good job with that
this is pretty well done
this one is actually really well done as
as well
ah man
i'm gonna say it ai satan you you got it
you got it i really like it i think you
did a good job
this looks great you got your nice
splines here
your liquid and everything character is
really well done
so congratulations you have won this
week's weekly challenge
and we have one more winner who is it
going to be
is it going to be the vfx wizard
bgi or the matrix
uh very tough but this one is good too
this one's really good
this one is missing the specular on the
walls
that's what i'm missing with this one is
the specular the matrix one doesn't
quite match the reference
you're missing the light here
that i'm seeing in the reference against
the rain it's just a little dark
you're not not seeing that silhouette
you really need that
uh that rain to be bright in order to
see his silhouette there
so it comes down to bgi with the planet
the only gripe on this one is the color
and the vfx wizard
really well done looks great
i don't know i think
i'm gonna have to say it's the vfx
wizard
um this one to me is just a bit more
unique than
the space scene the spacing is very well
done but this one just matches
the reference so well so congratulations
to the vfx wizard you are a weekly
challenge
winner this week you won last times too
you guys are just putting out good stuff
so thank you thank you so much
for participating and putting out all
these awesome submissions i really enjoy
doing this
it's really a lot of fun um so
you guys will be featured in the
weekly uh the challenge winners here
this was about a month and a half ago we
did this one
about a month ago because we had the
parallel dimensions contest
and this was video game these are all
the winners you can go all the way back
and see all the winners for all the
different prompts
it's a lot of good ones so i'll be
adding those very soon once the stream's
over
um and yeah let's figure out what
is this week's weekly challenge going to
be
what do you guys want to do i'm open to
suggestions we usually whittle it down
here on the stream
and figure out what you all want to do
oh sports we hadn't done that one yet
make an animation an animation is kind
of vague
but not bad a disney animation
[Music]
all right how about this since we're
doing rigging
and animating what if we um what if we
said the challenge was just a walk cycle
and you have to do a walk cycle with any
character you want
you can create the character you can
download the character but you must
do the walk cycle by hand no mocap
no miximo you have to do it by hand and
the the five best walk cycles will win
uh this week's or next week's weekly
challenge what do you guys think about
that
all right we got two yeses
all right we got a lot okay all right we
got people who are up for the challenge
um it doesn't matter if it's a robot it
doesn't matter if it's a
like a beanbag box thing as long as it
has a walk cycle
um i think that could be fun so that
that's it let's do it guys let's
let's learn a little bit um i might
try and do this myself actually i might
join you guys for this one we're gonna
do a walk cycle that's the weekly
challenge
it could be with any character um it
just
you can't use any mix of mode data you
can't do any mocap
it needs to be by hand you gotta animate
by hand
um so good luck to y'all it's gonna be a
hard one
but i hope that we can all learn some
cool stuff along the way because that's
the whole point of all this
is to learn what we can learn
all right so um if you guys need
clarification it'll be in the discord
server
under uh weekly challenge you guys get
the challenge there get the prompt there
and uh other than that yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna take a break here
i've been working a lot a whole lot
um but yeah if you guys hadn't check out
the render montage
i love how it turned out it really
really turned out
it's on my channel here i just uploaded
it like two hours ago
um share it with your friends share it
with your family
and uh yeah i'll see you guys in the
discord server this week have a good one
i'll catch you guys soon peace out
everybody have a good saturday have a
good sunday
be safe have fun